Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
continuing in Alwaji in the
chapter of bathing.
We are continuing the first of five
instances in which bathing is obligatory
upon a person. And that first instance
is
el janaba. Right? So bathing from el
janaba which el janab is a sexual
impurity that a person is in and it has
a couple of parameters.
One of the parameters that is lesser
known,
but it's probably lesser known because
it is a rare occurrence.
And that is that we mentioned once
a male
has an instance where there is
sperm. A person wakes up from sleep for
instance and finds that they have had a
wet dream even if they do not remember
it then they must bathe. And if a person
were to remember a wet dream but then
does not find any traces of that
physically upon waking then the person
does not bathe. Now, one of the lesserk
known instances is sperm
coming out
with force, forcefully coming out of
the body, being expelled from the body
with force. However, without
sexual pleasure involved, without
any sort of sexual climax,
without
you know without shah without
arousal.
Now this is something that is possible.
It is very improbable. It is highly
unlikely which is why we don't really
hear about it a lot but in this instance
this is
does not constitute
bathing
if this occurs when a person is awake.
When a person is awake,
[Silence]
Who are
Ramy? be po.
[Silence]
for.
So,
[Silence]
very unlikely event, But it is
something that is a possible
occurrence. And so the scholars they
have specifically given definitions
the scholars of FK they have given very
specific definitions on what
the things are that they research. So
for instance, if you look at
what is referred to as elmen
almani sperm sperm what is sperm
or semen in the legislation of Islam?
What does the legislation consider to be
semen
that
necessitates a person bathe? That's very
different than what is scientifically
considered to be semen. Correct? Or what
is considered to be seaman
outside of the scope of
when we are discussing the issue of
bathing from janaba. Let's say for
instance a person were to have some kind
of medical procedure where some kind of
I don't know if they do this but as a
as an example some kind of
you know needle is inserted to take out
some semen from a person.
, would this now necessitate that the
person
is in a state of janaba? Is this person
now obligated to bathe? Because we have
semen that's come out of the body.
Correct? We would say no. Why? Because
the semen that is expelled during se
sexual climax is what obligates
bathing.
[Silence]
Alim.
And so these are different instances.
Many of us, most of us may go through
our entire lives without coming crossing
paths with such an instance. But it is
possible and the scholars do mention
this. And so we've mentioned that
if
semen is expelled from the body
with force
due to
arousal.
This necessitates bathing.
Even if the person doesn't remember it,
let's say it was a wet dream. It
happened while he was sleeping. He does
not remember dreaming about that, but
they find the evidence of it when they
wake up. This person must bathe.
A another person has a dream and they
feel and they go through all of the
feelings of a wet dream. They wake up
and there is no evidence of a wet dream
physically. This person bathes or does
not bathe. Does not bathe. This all goes
back to the root narration.
Remember the narration that we started
this chapter with that
So that is the first instance that a
person must bathe. The second as
many
He was
the Muslim.
[Silence]
At the very beginning
of Islam,
it was only
that a person who
had
ex the expulsion of semen in the way
that we described with climax. This is
the only time a person would be
obligated to bathe.
And in Bkari a man asked
During the prophet's time saiam
he asked
if a person is intimate with his wife
has intercourse with his wife but does
not reach you know a conclusion to
that does not have a climax from that
and there is no semen
Does this person have to bathe? He said
this person has to make to wash his
private parts and make udul and that's
how it was at the beginning. This was
later abregated
and it became that intercourse between a
man and a woman. Intercourse is what
would obligate
jeneva. So if a person has intercourse
then this person is in considered to be
in a state of janaba even if they do not
reach
a sexual climax and what is the bare
minimum of intercourse what is it?
Well the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
defines this in great detail. He says if
the two private parts meet, meaning the
male and the female private parts, if
the two private parts meet, then bathing
is obligatory. And in this narration,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam places
another condition. The this all boils
down to the bare minimum of what Islam
Islamic legislation considers to be
intercourse
is the head of the penis entering the
private parts of the woman, the
vagina. This is the bare minimum. This
is what the scholars
mention. This is what the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam has mentioned to be
the bare minimum of intercourse. Usually
we you know try to steer clear of
explicit language.
However,
this is important because many people do
not know the difference or the bare
minimum of this. This doesn't just work
in the point of
janaba. This also works for instance
in the issue of fasting for instance.
What's the bare minimum of intercourse
that if a person does this their fasting
is invalid? They must fast two
consecutive months, right? As a
penance for this. Well, it is the head
entering. This is what we call
this is the bare minimum of intercourse
in the field of if this happens
if this bare minimum
occurs the person is in a state of
janva regardless of what happened after.
However, if this does not happen and
there is no expulsion of semen in the
way that we've described, then this
person does not have
Geneva. This is very important also
because a common question you'd be
surprised how common this question is is
that a person will bathe from janaba
and then when they finish bathing some
more semen comes out of their private
parts.
Does this person have to bathe again?
Semen came out right? Does this person
have to bathe again? What's the answer?
No. Why? Because it is only semen that
comes out
forcefully and semen which comes out due
to sexual climax. If that does not
happen, if those two things are not
occurring, then this is not considered
Geneva. Seaman technically came out but
not in the way that obligates jeneva. So
I've discussed this now in great detail
both of these issues. Tomorrow we can
move on inshallah wanted to get it out
of the way so as to finish the other two
the other three instances that
[Arabic recitation]